thanks to brilliant for sponsoring this
video hi I'm Toby and welcome back to
another video today I would like to show
you through one of the most influential
PhD theses ever written and that is the
work of Marie Curie in this thesis Marie
talks about the discovery of the new
elements radium and polonium and also
describes how she gained one of the
first understandings of the new physical
phenomenon of radioactivity there was
for that understanding that she was
awarded the Nobel Prize in 1903 the same
year this thesis was published and it
was a few years later that she gained
another Nobel Prize for the discovery of
those new elements this thesis was
published at the University of Sorbonne
in Paris when Marie was 35 and she was
the first woman in France to be awarded
a doctoral degree although she was
originally from Poland so with that
let's have a little look at this really
important work the title of the thesis
is research on radioactive substances
and it says it's by madam Sklodowska
Curie which is her full name and in fact
Marie is the French version of her
original name Maria this is a reprint of
the thesis done in 1904 and this is of
course not the original copy the link is
in the description to where I got this
from the original documents would
probably be quite contaminated with
radioactive substances so I wouldn't
want to be handling them this is the
table of contents and the original
version was in French but don't worry
I'll show you an English translation
soon this just shows us what some of the
chapters were about we have first an
introduction a look at the history of
the science then chapter one about the
radioactivity of uranium and thorium
which are radioactive materials and
radioactive is actually a word that
Marie used in this thesis to first
describe the phenomenon that she was
seeing
she then talks about some new
radioactive substances that she's found
and then the sub
when chapters talk about trying to
separate those new radioactive
substances by some really tough chemical
methods
let's get page 1 of the English version
over here the introduction says that the
work presented here has been worked on
for the last four years and that she is
being assisted by mr. Curie
that's pure her husband who has put
aside his own work to help her on this
new exciting field the work establishes
the existence of a new element radium at
the preparation of pure chloride of
radium and the determination of the
atomic weight of radium form the main
part of the work this new element they
have found has very curious properties
and also a new method of chemical
research is established this work was
kick-started by the discovery of röntgen
rays which we would call x-rays these
mysterious rays that could produce an
image of the bones in your hand caused a
lot of excitement and around this time
many new different kinds of mysterious
rays were being reported some what kind
of a false alarm but some were very
legit we have here that mr. Becker all
has made similar experiments on these
salts of uranium this paragraph here
explains that these penetrating uranium
rays were not a result of
phosphorescence that means that even
when the uranium compounds were placed
in complete darkness they still
continued to act on photographic plates
this was quite peculiar because at this
time it was thought that for energy to
be conserved
the only way for light to be emitted
from a material is for it to have been
first absorbed but if you're keeping
your uranium in the dark and you're
still seeing these rays then that
doesn't seem to fit with the model what
it took many more years to realize is
that energy is indeed being stored in
these materials but billions of years
ago
and stored in the form of mass chapter
one mentions that these uranium Ray's or
a bigger arrays cause a gas to become a
feeble conductor of electricity
with that murray develops a way to
measure the intensity of radiation of
uranium by the effect of this radiation
on the conductivity of air and down here
is where she calls substances which
generate liquor will raise radioactive
this is her experimental set up here
where she measures the intensity of
radiation what she does is to put a
powder of her radioactive substance on
this plate here and then she applies a
potential difference across these two
plates by setting up a circuit the
current in the circuit be an indication
of how well this material is acting as a
conductor and therefore of how intense
the radiation is and the way that she
got a measure of this current was having
this quartz crystal over here which is
stressed by having some weights placed
upon it this crystal is an example of
the piezoelectric effect which is when I
stressed crystal will cause electricity
to flow Marie's husband Pierre actually
discovered the piezoelectric effect in
1883 so he was really knowledgeable
about how to use this in the circuit and
what they did was to apply a current
that opposed the current in this circuit
and the amount of weight added to this
plate here would be a measure of how
strong a parent was needed to fully
oppose this conductivity Marie thought
that it would be improbable that
radioactivity would be a property
belonging to only one kind of matter so
she tested a variety of materials this
table contains the results of uranium
with a bunch of different uranium
minerals what is really unexpected and
important about these results is that
there are a few uranium minerals that
have a high
radioactivity and pure uranium this was
a massive clue to the existence of a
substance which was more radioactive
than uranium considering this she is
able to identify two new strongly
radioactive substances polonium which
she's named after her homeland of Poland
and radium they do a spectral analysis
to confirm that these elements are
different from elements that have
already been studied but they haven't
got a pure sample of these new elements
yet and the thesis then moves on to
using some pretty intense chemical
methods to get pure samples a pure
sample would be needed to measure things
like the atomic weight and officially
add these new substances to the periodic
table here Marie writes that after
working for several years to try and
isolate radium and polonium
she's only succeeded in isolating radium
she failed with polonium for a few
reasons
including the fact that polonium was
only present in the uranium ore in very
tiny trace amounts the method for
isolating radium that she describes over
the next few pages in the thesis
demonstrates that this was a brewing
task done on an enormous scale it shows
her courage and stamina in chemistry on
this page we see the description of
beautiful crystals which have formed and
that's one of only three or four
subjective aesthetic judgments which
have snuck their way in to the thesis
after starting with millions of grams of
raw material Marie ends up with a sample
of radium chloride which is about 1/10
of a gram on this page here we see her
finding the atomic weight of the sample
and this is the purest sample here with
only a trace of barium present she lists
the atomic weight as being 2 to 5 and
that's actually really close to the
aren't accepted value of two to six
that's really impressive for work that
was done in a very humble shed using
very difficult raw materials and
chemical processes that had never been
done before all to understand a
mysterious property that no one had even
measured before Murray mentions that for
radium the strength of the radioactivity
is on the order of ten to the six higher
than that of uranium and again this is
in the correct magnitude of our
currently accepted numbers and again is
a really great result I found it
interesting that Murray did know about
the different kinds of radiation alpha
beta and gamma rays as described by
Ernest Rutherford around the same time
and she has a little diagram here
showing these three different rays that
the gamma are the most penetrating that
alpha would be stopped after only a
short distance and that these have
opposite effect when acted on by a
magnetic field they didn't know what
these types of radiation were and in
fact the Curie's are trying to formulate
an explanation of their radioactivity
almost a decade before the atomic
nucleus would be discovered another page
from the thesis that I found interesting
was this one about the physiological
effects now it says here that radium
rays exert an action upon the epidermis
so they knew that radioactivity was
having some kind of biological effect
you may know that Marie Curie ultimately
died from a disease likely caused by her
exposure to radiation and that made me
think that they had no idea of the
effect of radiation on the body perhaps
it is true that they didn't know this
effect would be detrimental but the
experiments on this page at least show
that they knew it affected the skin in
one experiment mr. Curie caused a
relatively weak radioactive product to
act upon his arm for
ten hours the redness appeared
immediately and later a wound was caused
which took four months to heal
she then talks about some use of
radioactive materials in the hospital
for probably the treatment of cancers
and tumors and actually that became
something very useful about these
properties and we still do use
irradiation to treat cancers so when
used carefully it can actually save
lives but we're not treated carefully it
can also cost your lives chapter four
moves on to explaining what was
ultimately a role hypothesis that
radioactivity could be communicated from
one substance to another this idea was
caused by a few of their strange results
may be explained by the fact that their
samples were disappearing by radioactive
decay or being absorbed into the glass
radium is produced by the decay of
uranium and that is why they are always
found together but Marie never commented
on this fact of why these two seemingly
different elements would always be found
together and maybe if she had it would
have been more of a clue to explaining
what was really going on we will finish
by going through Murray's conclusions
the only sentence that she chooses to
put in italics is that radium is a new
chemical element so she was really proud
of this discovery of a new element and
that is what she is often known for
today it's true that this is a very
impressive contribution but even more so
is their discovery of the property of
radioactivity and she sums it up at the
bottom here our researchers upon the new
radioactive bodies have given rise to a
scientific movement indeed this would be
the starting point for a lot more
science and a lot more discoveries about
the nature of the atom why radiation
occurs and how we can use it so that has
been a look at Marie Curie's work
if you're feeling inspired then you
should check out today's sponsor
brilliant set a goal to improve your
scientific knowledge and chip away at it
every day
brilliant makes that possible with their
interactive explorations and they have a
mobile app so you can learn wherever you
are their course on the chemical
reaction will help to understand more
about how matter transforms and to other
substances which you may be interested
in if you enjoyed learning about Marie
Curie's work and chemistry you can head
to brilliant org slash Toby's the link
is below and the first 200 people to do
so will get 20% off their annual
subscription thanks to brilliant and
thanks to my patreon supporters for
making this video possible including
today's patreon cat of the day flash
also thank you for watching and I'll see
you next time
you
[Music]